voici le rang des genêts un chef qui
filme des recettes en 60 secondes top
chrono bienvenue sur techtoc
ici tout est calculé à la seconde près
mamie on a plus de beurre pour mettre
sur notre pain pour ces fascinants du
beurre je connais la recette
en l'espace de quelques mois tik tok est
devenu la plateforme sur la planète pour
partager des recettes le jus de citron
vert un peu de sel poivre du paprika et
un peu de coriandre fraîche partout des
chefs et aussi de simples citoyens pour
nous proposer leur bonne idée appelez ça
comme vous mais l'important c'est que
c'est délicieux et les statistiques sont
étourdissantes nom n'est donc plus
brasser les tacos ses 26 points 5
millions de vues
toussaint vidéo en grèce avec des
poissons grillés dpm prier jeu vidéo à
paris sur un toit je fais ça motive
jambon beurre
[Musique]
avec sa partenaire amandine ils ont
réalisé plus de 60 vidéos tout a
commencé avec un somme en tête c'était
notre troisième vidéo c'est un gravlax
de saumon on a mis en ligne le soir à
reims couché là mais on s'est réveillé
avec mon téléphone quittant rennes 2
complètement explosif de la notification
s'en allait qui suit est comme pris 1
million projet millions de vu un ennui
nous est petit pour être suivi par des
millions
fait mon concubin mis environ 10 ans est
en plein chaos j'ai commencé à faire des
vidéos sur instagram techtoc et ce sera
parti en flèche depuis environ dix mois
est rendu à plus d'un million d'abonnés
puis ces enzymes un job à temps plein
phare des vidéos comme stop
[Applaudissements]
à date je regarde pas du tout le disons
que en une seule vidéo j'ai fait environ
pour moi de ce que je faisais avec moi
c'est l'emploi à 3 h concert des trous
au beau fixe et ça vient d'où cet argent
là les commanditaires ont ni de baisse
mais romain christe haut
depuis 2000 ans jean l'appartement est
resté sont tellement faciles qui
s'adonnent talents d'idées de choses
auxquelles je n'ai juste pas penser ça
donne aussi accès à plusieurs cultures
[Musique]
c'est vraiment facile d'en trouver sur
un réseau ce sacrifice
sans surprise ce sont surtout les jeunes
qui ont adopté la plateforme la moitié
des usagers au moins de 34 ans le tiers
n'ont pas encore 19 ans simon et flora
s'en servent tous les jours c'est midi
je fais des tos à l'avocat est fauché
maintenant elle en est une que je suis
tout ces trucs ces cinq se voir c'est
une des trucs qui ont l'air vraiment
facile samedi moi j'aime ce genre quand
je sais que ça va pas être très long
mais je sais que ça est très bon mais
j'ai voulu
d'elle faille j'ai l'impression puisque
attire vraiment en fait l'histoire c'est
le fait que les vidéos soient très
courte puis c'est punchy
depuis 2014 la nutritionniste cynthia
marcotte s'intéresse à l'impact des
réseaux sociaux sur l'alimentation
pourquoi l'alimentation une place aussi
importante sortie club d'après les gens
cherchent des solutions rapides solution
efficace qui vont les aider au quotidien
donc que ce soit que d'abord des petits
et petites vidéos avec là on voit
vraiment la mise en place on voit
comment t'est ce qu'on veut venir mais
seront données sur les aliments puis le
résultat final qui sut pas rapper de
sang mais aussi les gens adorent combien
de temps par jour veut passer sur tic
tac moi c'est beaucoup
avancé presse puis maintenant je me sens
mais une limite de temps sur mon
téléphone
par jour est-ce que vous cuisinez ou est
ce que vous regardez des vidéos cuisine
ben j'ai beaucoup plus de vidéos que
j'ai enregistré
et mixé les classiques là que tout le
monde fait pendant une semaine c'est la
même recette tient partout sur peter
facture ça c'est sûr que ça donne plus
envie d'essayer
comme quoi par exemple jamais fait à
l'entente où les restes de partho fait
ça a l'air bon cette presse est là est
juste tellement simple et vraiment comme
une plaque un chaudron ça prend quinze
minutes c'est fini comme le tonfa cuire
les pâtes et ont tout fait
si elles ont adopté la plateforme elles
ne sont pas naïve pour autant ce que tu
as envie que ces réseaux sociaux qui est
accessible à tous il ya beaucoup de gens
qui font de la désinformation 100% tu
peux commencer à faire des vidéos sur la
nutrition m'étais pas nutritionniste
importe il ya quand même des
spécialistes de plus en plus je trouve
qu'ils commencent à dire que si les
informations ne sont pas nécessairement
la sphère loup leclerc ici il nous
présente la son expérience de gens de
plus de 72 heures vous êtes plusieurs à
ma vo pose des questions pour connaître
mon avis de l'udc sionisme je vous en
parle ici rétablir des faits dans ce qui
est un peu le far west en termes de
contenu sur l'alimentation et les
régimes cynthia ans le fait son cheval
de bataille
en fait mon domaine là je parle beaucoup
de cultures des diètes donc deux
solutions pour perdre du poids
rapidement par exemple et il ya des gens
par exemple qui vont donner des conseils
très inapproprié donc ils vont proposer
des suppléments des coupe faim des
jeunes il a ce moment la mode c'est sûr
que j'ai beaucoup de contenu qui est du
conduit en duo qu'on appelle donc on va
faire une critique face à une vidéo qui
était déjà qualifié par une autre
personne sur la plate forme pour mon
métier je pense que c'est aussi une
façon de faire voyager d'informer
message donc de toucher au plus de gens
possible qu'il communauté aussi que je
touchais peut-être pas autant que je
l'aurais mis avant donc les jeunes est
donc d'aller partager mes messages qui
sont vraiment plus dans la bienveillance
évitez aussi à ces jeunes-là tomber dans
la culture de dieppe l'europe s'est
tordu otfried pêcheries est il réel
rejoindre le plus de monde possible et
cueillir au passage son petit 15
secondes de gloire ça semble être le but
de tous les types de coeur j'ai
l'original à la cannelle je vais tester
à l'instant comme cet étudiant qui fait
des critiques de resto pour ses cent
trente mille abonnés c'est un loisirs
j'aime beaucoup ça que devant la caméra
par des vidéos fin du montage puis
partager ce que j'aime un public est ce
qu'on peut donner les crédibilité à des
vidéos qui ont une minute maximum et qui
sont vus parfois même quand même entier
oui absolument je pense que sadc servir
à sauver sans vie au même problème que
toutes les plateformes ça dépend de la
personne qui l'a présent
je suis avec bientôt pour la recette du
saumon steria qui est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui ricardo ou pour la vie je
pense que maintenant le contenu sont
intactes dorian crédibilité parce qu'il
ya beaucoup plus de personnes c'est des
médecins des avocats ou est juste une du
monde sont passionnés ils sont sur un
sujet qui partagent leur passion sur
cette plateforme le honnêtement
suffisent wahou
ou un succès certes table pour vous
personnellement tu sais quoi quand les
gens disent que j'ai fait une différence
dans leur vie ou d'avoir plus confiance
en eux ce ça fait 2 0 je pense que c'est
quand même la chose dont les réseaux
sociaux qui est pas à crier leur si les
gens consacrent plus de cuisine ça
donnait pas négatif pour nous au
contraire et c'est tabou
nos trois types tucker ont produit des
vidéos spécifiquement pour ce reportage
et elles sont disponibles maintenant sur
leurs pages respectives
l'épicerie n'est pas encore sûr tik tok
mais allez nous voir sur facebook et
instagram
[Musique]